greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
out it listen when it comes to
supplements debtor once they gotta had a
great sale going on right now I'm the
protein pie on the way protein they got
oh my god they got the alpha brain in
the powder form now that you could just
put into a water they got alpha brain
they got shroom text room taking me
listen they never seem to cease to amaze
me that's why I love on it most thing is
alpha brains their flagship on the
percent money-back guarantee things they
don't even want the product back if it
don't work out for you go to Anna calm
right now press in church and get 10%
off your first order delivered to your
house number two the church would love
to welcome up start as most of you have
found out the hard way getting into debt
is easy getting out is hard alright
especially if your FICO score isn't
great thankfully now there's upstart
calm the revolutionary new lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score and it offers
smaller interest rates to help you pay
off those high entry credit card debt
upstart goes beyond the traditional FICO
score when assessing your
creditworthiness they actually they
reward you based on your education and
your job history in the form of a
smaller interest rate huh come on now
see why upstart is ranked number one in
their category with over 300 businesses
on Trustpilot and harry the upstart coms
last Church that's upstart dot Tom's
last Church to find out how low your up
start rate is checking your rate only
takes a few minutes and it won't affect
your credit that's upstart com slash
Church kick this [ __ ] mealy
[ __ ] Thursday morning this is the
type of music I put on in the morning
when I want to stab a [ __ ] when
I'm leaving the house ready to [ __ ]
take care of business this is the type
of [ __ ] I put on this the Allman
Brothers whipping post I remind myself
that I'm a piece of [ __ ] I'm going out
to the earn what's coming to me
understand me to earn to take back what
[ __ ] belongs to me anyway
we got no guests uncle Joey and the
[ __ ] crowd the crazy [ __ ] Jew over
here I want to talk to you people about
something real serious I'll get you in
and out he thought I got things to do
and people to see myself you know every
a couple of weeks we do a 1 and we pick
a topic and I tell you what topic has
been lacking completely lately and it
lacked from my life from a long [ __ ]
time and I had a little bit of it but it
was until I got burnt and realized I was
a piece of [ __ ] without it that you
don't even think about that word it's
called respect and I'm not talking about
respect like in the movies like on The
Sopranos on a mafia movie that there's
so much respect was the Mafia they all
rat on each other
where's that respect my point is just a
respect of that when I was younger I was
taught to respect people with white hair
you know older people and I did that I
listened to my mother and I pay
attention but I had no respect for
society what did that mean I lit fires I
drew things out my window you know I
[ __ ] didn't through [ __ ] rocks off
the bridge in Union City when cars were
going under the underpass I'm gonna had
no respect and I was a kid and I was
stupid and we all stupid when it comes
to that point but I also had no respect
when I turned 16 17 18 first one I
respect for myself because I was doing
drugs so when you're [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
you're not supposed to be doing a thief
and you have taken away the respect for
yourself once you take away the respect
for yourself what's left
you're really gonna respect somebody who
tells you to be there 8:00 in the
morning no because you took a way to
respect from your life by doing by
crossing personal lines that you're not
supposed to [ __ ] cross so it's so we
and how it took me going to jail it took
me doing a lot of things to get that
respect and it wasn't and if he I can
say if you want me to tell you it was
jail they told me respect it was it was
one thing it was the religion that got
me to where I am today and it's called
comedy calmly taught me that you had to
have so much respect I love when you
guys put a get you know Johnny Watson or
put Joe bananas on the show listen first
of all I don't know he's
I don't know he's beam I don't know him
would you invite somebody how if you
didn't know no I don't know these
[ __ ] people all right I got my little
back kV it's fenced off we are cameras
here I don't want nobody here I don't
want you don't want me your husband I
want you at my [ __ ] house all right
when I look at different comics that I
bring in here they might you might not
agree with them because the female the
male may be their prop back but I've
known him a lot longer than you do and
they gained my respect by something that
they did do you think Rogan gained my
respect by going to the UFC or he gained
my respect because he can throw a kick
oh he did DMT that's not how he got my
respect he got my respect because when
he was on the show making an enormous
amount of money on NBC called news radio
after he would tape on Fridays he would
still come down to the comedy show to
pick up his $15 check there's people
that can't [ __ ] walk after taping a
[ __ ] TV show for 12 hours
never mind drive to the comedy store
afterward and do a 15 [ __ ] dollar set
why would you be making [ __ ] I don't
even know what he was making but why
would you be that's when they were
paying on sitcoms why would you be
making all that money and then stop what
you're doing and go to the comedy store
for $15 that showed me a different type
of respect that showed me that even when
you get a TV show you have to continue
grinding because of that show gets
cancelled then you're gonna be a [ __ ]
month you were too busy spending money
hanging out with Jennifer Aniston that's
the [ __ ] whatever you're a big shot
now but you turned your back on the most
important thing which is comedy that's a
completely different story respect it is
huge when you become a comedian it's
huge it becomes bigger why do you think
I tell you [ __ ] to respect
little things because little things
become big things I've sat here with Lee
and totally a thousand reasons why you
eat the certain things you do and it's
not even for your health that's how I
started what respect you're from the
east coast I didn't even [ __ ] that
was that Petey's
you'll stand on line with those [ __ ]
Gentiles no pizza right how you gonna do
that yeah and you have to put your foot
down as an East Coaster no I'm not
eating that I'm not eating that
okay this is the last piece on earth I'm
not even that's it and you don't eat it
starts with little things you know
little things a respect no I will not
even look at that mother [ __ ] who
played Charles Bronson the mechanic I
think that was the biggest breach of
disrespect in the history of [ __ ]
film and then to chop up the movie you
sitting there going Joey you [ __ ] say
me I am [ __ ] serious
I am [ __ ] serious you know I have a
dear dear dear dear friend listening to
the podcast his name is George
his mom was a [ __ ] tremendous cook
rest in peace I loved her with all my
heart let me say how [ __ ] crazy I am
okay what 1933 which made me thirty
years oh my god serious about stand up
that wasn't I really really really
jumped into stand up was in 1993 I she
asked me one day you know what do you
want to eat or something she made that
spaghetti and clam sauce I don't know
what that she was at manna mania and
something else but didn't matter she
made a spaghetti and clam sauce that
would knock your [ __ ] socks off
the sauce was creamier than usual you
ever get spaghetti and clam sauce it's
like pasta with a broth on top and they
throw a bunch of clams that's not
spaghetti he claims us
that's some [ __ ] malfunction that you
[ __ ] learn somewhere along the line
you know well it's got a lot of clams
there yeah but it's just a [ __ ]
chicken soup broth I'm part of my when
it goes into the pasta when you bite the
pasta these [ __ ] idiots forgot what
that is bloody wait to make a long story
short we're talking one day and she says
to me that what do you want I don't want
you to make me spaghetti in clam sauce
alright so the next day I saw my buddy
Chrissy fish and I asked him for a bag
of must a bag of clams and he gave me a
beautiful bag of these [ __ ] clams or
[ __ ] fresh I just got him from the
from the fish Martin had just gotten
from the fish market that morning
took the [ __ ] crabs I borrowed his
truck
I took the clams bought his truck drove
to Mitzi's at about 12 o'clock she was
just getting ready for the Danakil mitts
here's the clams for the spaghetti and
clam sauce boom she's like that [ __ ]
beautiful where'd you get these they're
like those nice cherry stones whatever
the [ __ ] I come back that night 8
o'clock now listen I'm the type of dude
that once you tell me you're making
something that's all I'm thinking about
if you tell me you're gonna make me
chicken cutlets with creamed corn and
mashed potatoes and I got over your
house and there's a salad we don't talk
that's not what was on the menu that's
not how you got me here you lied to me
how eat the chicken cutlets oh I eat the
salad but now I got a push on it to
watch list like you're a [ __ ]
terrorist because you [ __ ] with my
emotions all dad was thinking about
those mashed potatoes and the [ __ ]
cranberry juice with the Seltzer in it
and I'm saying then you have like
[ __ ] Diet Coke
I need this what happened to the
cranberries use it yourself so anyway to
make a long story short I get the
[ __ ] Mitzi's oscillator clock I
stopped I got off the bus and walk like
a mile to get an extra piece of nice
bread I get to a house I go Mets and
George was there I don't know George was
there
grandma was diagonal Mets what's up she
goes I'm in the back
help yourself it's beautiful now when I
walked them I smelt this weird odor
right I smoked this odor that I knew I
did not like but it doesn't matter
because I was there for the spaghetti
and clam sauce when I opened the pot for
the spaghetti and clam sauce the odor
hit me in my face
and this thing was like green I slammed
the thing down she came and she's like
he's gonna get a plate I go Mitch what
is this and she goes that's spaghetti
and clam sauce but I tried a new recipe
I put curry in it I [ __ ] took my hat
put it on I walked out and I didn't talk
to her for probably two years after that
that's how serious I am that she
insulted me that daily a couple of years
before that I want the Thanksgiving that
some [ __ ] [ __ ] outs over I'm just
getting a little white [ __ ] here in LA
she
a casting director Thanksgiving at nine
o'clock who has Thanksgiving at nine
o'clock at night so all day long you sit
there and eat crackers by yourself I
knew there was a rat but I had agreed to
it and all my friends were gonna go up
there so I went with these [ __ ]
morons my wife was my girlfriend at the
time we had been dating for about two
years she advised me not to do it though
let's have Thanksgiving in the house me
I was trying to be jolly nice guy I get
up there and she served those potatoes
that come from a box you know those
mashed potatoes in mash when I see
instant mashed potatoes I think of
prison and I think of Papillon I think
of bad situations in my life because I
grew up I'm 56 years old and I can tell
you that seriously seriously I don't
know anybody who ever use box mashed
potatoes they're so easy to make well
you listen just shut up no no I'm saying
no no like I haven't gonna [ __ ] talk
to you like if you used mashed potatoes
out of a box I can't come up with the
house I really can't
it's just a lack of respect like you
just really you can't put a potato and
boil it and chop it up even [ __ ] the
mortadella over here just said it's easy
to make mashed potatoes a little sour
cream a little milk even me it's a
[ __ ] the worst cook in the world
I could put together mashed potatoes
limite some and then she stuffed a
turkey no no it didn't end there it
didn't end there like my blood pressure
didn't [ __ ] go over $2,000 how many
years ago 20 years it's gonna be 15
years she was dating a guy named Vinny a
real [ __ ] loser
and I was planning on robbing Vinny
Vinny had to owed the government money
and he was stashing 200 large in the
trunk of his car and drive around with
it oh no and then this girl was flapping
about telling people she didn't know I
was ready to take this guy out he just
had a secured gate I had to figure out
how to get to the secure gate and hide
and then I would call her she come down
with him and I clock him in the head but
she's a nice kid she's from Texas you
know she was like a Jersey girl I can
set him up and we'd split the money
because what the guy was gonna say
another guy went 80 pounds
with with if he had two rocks in his
pocket that's what I got this is how
broken I was at the time she told me one
day she's like he has a lot of money cuz
he owes the IRS money so he keeps in the
trunk of his car I'm like that's all I
needed to know I walked I walked over
there a couple of nights encased a nap
he parked his car right next to the
[ __ ] sliding gate so all I had to do
was wait for the gate to open slide and
hide him the car was a little fat at the
time so if I got under the [ __ ] car
who tipped it over like a half dozen
would have been [ __ ] on two legs so I
would have to hide behind the car with a
pipe and hit him and make sure there was
no cameras and dress in black and then I
couldn't put my wife in on it Sam he's I
had a walked they couldn't borrow her
car you really thought this whole thing
out oh yeah no no this is what people
like me do so so okay so they lived you
know when you make okay it's not they
lived on orange between Hollywood
Boulevard and Franklin okay so the 101
has access right there all I gotta do is
well [ __ ] boom and I'm on the one or
what that wasn't the problem I didn't
want to do it the car because the only
car had access to was see if I was in
Jersey I could borrow any of my friends
cards not even town right let them get a
call and let them get surprised and they
get mad at me and then it all goes away
cuz it wasn't then I would switch the
plates and get a different plate and
borrow their car I thought about doing
the same thing with my why it takes you
10 minutes to steal plates with me but
you know me the packages they stole from
your house yeah you can steal place in
the [ __ ] parking garage oh sure no
just steal two plates put them on your
[ __ ] car cuz you're only going around
the corner so you drive side streets but
it was Terry's card it was in her name
she didn't need the [ __ ] dough so I
just figured since they only lived about
a mile from my house it was even easier
I could bang him on the head take the
package put it in my own bag drop his
back there with gloves walk out on to
Franklin walk down Franklin to Highland
and just hoof it down the block the
[ __ ] Hollywood Boulevard there I am
with 800 people good luck yeah this is
way before technology and the faced
stuff and he wouldn't have caught me and
he wouldn't have said nothing so what
did you put in that turkey to make you
hate him so much a [ __ ] a duck
I don't you better track in letcher
Duncan and I didn't get the surprise - I
tasted it and it tasted like [ __ ]
somebody's [ __ ]
so I put the fork down and probably I
was ready to start [ __ ] crying and my
wife saw me that I wasn't ready to cry
so I basically got up and went outside
and smoke like 18 cigarettes because I
was so angry and I grabbed my wife and I
said let's get the [ __ ] out of here
the point is I didn't talk to Stacy from
November that year
- like the following June and when she
called me I was still so bad like she
kept calling me she kept calling me like
why is he talking to me what's the
problem and what is I was all [ __ ] up
and she called me and I saw was her and
she kept I don't know how I knew what
she wanted Oh what she called me she
goes I need to know why you are so angry
at me and I know what you need to do is
get a cookbook and I hung up on that's
how pissed off I was at it cuz I know
really well I love it at that but I
thought that she knew better she's
[ __ ] taxes who makes [ __ ] mashed
potatoes out of a bottle Thanks
that's what happens to white people from
Texas and they come up here they start
hanging with these [ __ ] granola heads
and he's [ __ ] oh my god these long
pollutin had [ __ ] and then they
become soft I seen it a thousand times
some Texans are [ __ ] tough to the
death I love Texans I ain't say nothin
bad about Texas but she's one of those
taxes that's like from Houston from the
yuppie side you know they jump up and
down and all that [ __ ] I still love her
I still talk about three times a week I
break the balls but my point is that
little things become big things and it's
a joke for some people and it's a joke
but I take it that seriously because if
I didn't take the little things that
seriously I wouldn't take the bait
things that seriously you know when you
become a comedian Asst there's different
protocols that you have to do when you
have to respect and if you go outside
those protocols then we have nothing
it's like everything else in life you
know I love the UFC I love to watch
fights who does who doesn't want to see
a fight but I'll tell you what I didn't
like I didn't like the UFC when
started with the trash-talking because
like I've always said what Lisa I acted
get away with what Joe Diaz could get
away with there's two different things
with Joe Diaz could get away with Joe
Rogan to get away with it's two
completely completely different things
so even with the UFC that little lack of
respect and no disrespect for them it
started with channel summative and this
and so and if you look and listen to the
tapes and whatever as much as I like
Channel there were some awkward thing
said that you know listen you want to
call me fat ugly what the prison that's
that's understandable I put that out
there so these are my choices once you
go beyond that barrier then it becomes
personal and now you're baiting me and
now I understand what you're doing
psychologically didn't work with jail
you know it didn't work for [ __ ]
McGregor against khabib you know it just
it's a respect thing you know Marva Dao
got asked the same thing a couple of
weeks ago and he gave his answer and I
put over it that it was white privilege
and people got pissed off at me I wasn't
it's the truth some people could say
some things and some well that's let's
just do this let's nobody say nothing
let's nobody say nothing let's go back
to being gentlemen and we won't have
this [ __ ] problem
there's some well it's a martial art
there has to be a respect there's
something I hate one anything in life
more than anything in life when I go to
a martial arts class and it only happens
in California when I was in Jersey as a
kid as a child where do you think I got
that thing is from you couldn't be you
had a if a martial arts class started
for you had to be there at 3:45 not 355
about 350 not 351 not 348 345 you had to
go on the bag take your slippers off put
your [ __ ] gear or if you walked in
with Yugi you ever see those fat little
kids with a gear and McDonald's after
class and you want to smack the parent
take the year off nobody knows you
little fat [ __ ] takes karate they
gonna pick on him even more now
it's unbelievable take the [ __ ] heat
off you got him gonna [ __ ] McDonald's
in the karate suit on like he's [ __ ]
bong hyung who'll take the [ __ ] suit
off for it give the kid a break
he looks like a dummy is that his I got
a karate suit on the [ __ ] head in the
[ __ ] Burger King you [ __ ] mutt
anyway so I don't know some [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know what
bothered me for I'm sorry you know you
sure you dressed up like the Korean
dictator at [ __ ] Dan Tana's with that
[ __ ] Eddie Munster suit on you need
that [ __ ] in your life just wear the
cloak and bow that's all you need to do
it
it's [ __ ] fun it's serious so you
broke my [ __ ] training dog [ __ ]
so what I'm trying to say is here yeah
you had to get there early to get there
you know in California these people walk
in after the warmups they walk in during
the warmups
oh god forbid there's a celebrity in the
class you got to see how he acts you
think he does the warm-up yeah I hope
they don't take to Hana barbells start
doing curls just to show that he's a
celebrity that's why most of the
celebrities just the [ __ ] teachers
tell them they got to do privates
because they think could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want
if remember if you book a pride with
John Joc it's 400 miles an hour if you
show up at ten after 4:00 that's for ten
minutes out of your time he's still
gonna stop the [ __ ] thing at four
o'clock he's only gonna give you at that
hour and that's the respect you have to
give people but most importantly it's a
respect that you give around you let me
tell you something Tommy have had a few
for lots of people but it's just like
life it's just like I know that people
listen to the podcasts are very nice
people but I know that you don't like
some of the people in your office I know
that may be your boss you don't like
them we're not programmed to like
everybody God wants us to love everybody
and we do in a sense until they rear end
this and then they got no insurance
you know I'm saying throw your energy
they got no insurance you know you're
[ __ ] pissed off at but you can
respect
everyone doesn't have to like them
absolutely abso-fucking-lutely so just
listen there's a thousand comics I don't
want to hang out with I don't want to
take him to dinner
I barely want to see them at the club
but I respect them for what they did I
knew about a situation in their life
where they went down just like every
other [ __ ] comic and they took that
pot negative and turned it into a
positive
you know I could tell you thirty of
those [ __ ] stories and why these
people are my personal heroes from
Felipe Esparza the Kevin Hart to bill
burr you know I saw these guys in a flip
moment ten years ago you two came to me
when Kevin Hart show failed on ABC and
told me he was in the sell more tickets
than any [ __ ] band in the [ __ ]
world last year I'd say to you I could
see it and I wish it does but I can't
see it but he knew something I didn't
when I saw bill burr after the show got
canceled in 98 and he was upset that
this was the biggest shot of his life
and it's blown I under you know I knew I
first opened bill burr told me that I
knew his world wasn't over there was no
[ __ ] way I just know it he was too
funny even back [ __ ] then he was
hysterical so I knew his world wasn't
over he regrouped took a plan and make
them now you have to give him the
respect he [ __ ] deserves just because
you may not like a [ __ ] comic
well I saw a special and he see you
could name me any comic and I'll show
you a certain respect level that I have
for them Jim Carrey I'm not a big
[ __ ] Jim Carrey fan oh yeah I'm a fan
of his first [ __ ] two movies but
after that I heard a couple things I've
seen him a couple of times he put me on
his TV show I'm not a big Jim Carrey fan
as a [ __ ] like I'm supposed to fall
over myself like most people are but I
will tell you [ __ ] man he lived in a
van for a long time with his [ __ ]
family and then every time he has today
he deserves for what he went through I
know what it is to sleep in a van
is to sleep in the park I know what it
is to sleep on a [ __ ] apartment that
will assist me buy a house you know when
I went on the road with Joe Rogan I know
whether this is sleep on the four
seasons and I also know what it is to go
on the road on the triple run and know
how to sleep on a motel 6 that smells
like [ __ ] you know like you're in
[ __ ] Baghdad you know between the
gunpowder and the sandal dust you don't
know what's worst you know so my point
is that you get the respect certain
people even if you don't like them for
what they've done
you know when you get when you have when
you're a comedian you get certain times
like when Lee goes with me on the ice
house last week Lee got 10 minutes
Rachel got 15 you know now you get a
thing called the light leave the guy
will come up to Lee and League how many
minutes should do a look at me he'll
give him time give Rachel 20 and I'll
give me a light at 40 okay
when that light comes on that means to
wrap it the [ __ ] up that means no matter
where you were wrap it the [ __ ] up but
if you do 11 and destroy that if you do
13 and the place looks like the [ __ ]
Garlic Festival running out like
Godzilla's showing up right I'm not mad
at you
oh that's a good thing okay I'm mad at
you no you know it when I go out stage
if I got a wider 40 and I do and I'm
supposed to get off with 50 and I do 56
I'm not really mad at me at all like I
understand those things you're in a
momentum type era it's when I give Lee
the light and he not he doesn't just
wrap it up but he starts another bit
another bit right and they'll do 21
and yeah he did okay and I'm proud of
him at all but he did something along
the line that you're not supposed to do
he went on for his life okay
so when you go over your light you're
telling me as a comic that you really
don't give a [ __ ] about you or the rest
of the show let me tell you something I
know when I'm [ __ ] bombing nobody has
to tell me well I didn't New Orleans
this year I felt I wasn't getting the
reception maybe my timing was off the
humidity
I failed you guys you know when I went
to Charlotte I had good SATs on I went
to Columbus I had great sets but last
night I ate two decks I went out to the
comedy store I did Rogen show didn't
really connect with them and the
original man didn't really connect with
them either I get that
i'ma tell you what I don't like if I'm
having a bad set just out it just out
let your time don't stay up there and
make it worse and run the light and then
ruin the show for you then to the comics
behind you because you're part of
something bigger than you when you go up
there and run the light you're telling
me that you don't give a [ __ ] about us
that you don't give a [ __ ] about the
other comics one listen I'm not gonna
lie to you when I was a feature act and
I went to the comedy store and I got
really good at featuring what's really
good at featuring a deadly 25 I had a
deadly 25 if you gave me 35 I wouldn't
even be close and how good I was I had
that 25-minute spot to a [ __ ] that
sentence and from the 21st minute to the
20th over the 29th from the 21st minute
to the 25th you were gonna roll you were
gonna die now there was a couple clubs I
was going to where the owner would pull
me aside and say listen this headliner
tonight is gonna have a hard time
following you I want you to whip him a
little bit because he sucks dick he's
been asked
me for more money serve you whip him a
little bit I did that and I gotta tell
you some that I didn't know then but I
know now or I realized years later that
was wrong that was wrong because I
shouldn't have been going up there as a
feature act and trying to steal the show
a couple of weeks ago we asked me what
was the difference between going on the
road and doing a show at The Comedy
Store and I said when I go on the road I
gonna give you a show when I go to calm
me start gonna be remembered I did not
say oh I'm going there to take over the
show or to be the funniest guy but I say
those words now no I said to be
remembered what does that mean to do the
best I could do to believe my heart on
the [ __ ] stage and to make you laugh
okay well I'm bailing when I'm dying
once that light comes on I know I died I
know I failed you as a comic and I felt
myself as a comic I feel bad enough I'm
getting the [ __ ] off there but you ever
go to a room with a guy is bomb another
woman is bombing and she gets a light
and then she extends it and now you just
given a all the coughing all the way
around the coffins already shut nice
just nail in the middle the [ __ ] with
the guy like to be to be like a Chinese
torture bed or whatever the [ __ ] they
call him like a better nail that's
disrespectful because you're really
ruining the show I'm gonna tell you guys
something okay right off the bat I don't
know what you guys think
like right now they get me that they
want me to add second shows to these
theaters and I don't want to do it I'll
tell you why because I don't get to see
you guys after the show I don't like to
show Knights because I cannot shake your
hand the shows we have so much little
time in between shows that they need to
seat and I don't it's just too crowded
in these comedy clubs I stick around for
the second show and I shake hands and I
take pictures when I go to a theater I
come out the reason why I'm not adding
an extra shows and the Borgata is
because of that
I don't want that you guys sold that out
in a [ __ ] week
what am I gonna do let you guys come in
for the Early Show I want to come out
there I want to walk around I'm gonna
gamble a little bit I want to talk some
[ __ ] you know now when I do those two
show nights let me tell you something if
you came to Columbus or you came to
Charlotte this year any of my shows you
guys know that when I finish at 52 or 56
I still got another 15 minutes left
you do know that I got another 15
minutes left
especially if I open up with material
out of the air and I buy myself time I
got another 15 minutes left and I can
give you but I can't give it to you do
you know why because there's people
outside standing on line and they could
be out there in the [ __ ] rain and you
ever show up somewhere there's a long
line and like what's going on well the
comic went late so now the show's gonna
run late now these poor [ __ ] people
are standing outside so yeah by me doing
some more time and you guys getting a
longer show I'm [ __ ] the people in
the second show because I'm making them
stand out they're like [ __ ] mooks on
the middle of the street Lisa at do I
stand on line anyway now I refuse I
don't need to go there that bad when I
fly I have clear that's to avoid the
line when I fly I cut what'd I tell you
guys well I got first-class ticket or
not I got on the first-class line
there's always three people on there I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm not standing on
that [ __ ] line and if you don't let
me in I'll leave for an hour and I'll
come back and try to get but I'll still
I don't want to stand on line me going
to Austin to stand on line for barbecue
you got a better chance of seeing your
mom in a high school porno then [ __ ]
thinking that I'm gonna go to Austin and
stand on line for your [ __ ] meat
you're out of your [ __ ] mind you
better hire more people or [ __ ] get
your productivity levels up but me
standing on line is not a cool [ __ ]
thing for me and never has and if you
like standing on line you know what you
better rethink your [ __ ] life I don't
want to stand on line so I know when I'm
onstage I got it
the [ __ ] time but guess what I gotta
respect those people out there and you
know what out of respect I'll give them
the same 54 minutes show because I don't
want no nothing I don't want you to bump
into one of them and to one of them to
say well he did it now in 15 oh [ __ ] he
only did 52 with us he went it was so
fast so I'm always thinking about the
respect there's respect factor I didn't
have that train of thought when I was a
[ __ ] civilian ain't nothing fences
doors windows I didn't give a [ __ ] about
rules but for you to get anywhere in
life it starts with responsibilities and
responsibilities cousins to respect
responsibility isn't that right cousin
to [ __ ] respect
because without responsibility you won't
have no respect or without respect you
won't have no [ __ ] responsibility I
could say to you guys you know what I'm
coming to [ __ ] that ball God DC next
week the Lincoln the Lincoln Theater do
I have to get on stage something I don't
have to do [ __ ] I could go into [ __ ]
Lincoln into DC next Friday without
doing a [ __ ] set till then I take my
chances and I don't really go [ __ ]
whether you like me and not or whether
you happy enough do you think I would do
something like that to you guys not at
all I'm doing two shows tomorrow night
we're doing a show Sunday night and I'll
do two shows Tuesday night then I get on
a plane so I'll do I'll do another show
Thursday night so I'm ready for you guys
and I'm not saying I'm not gonna bomb
I'm my bomb the percentages are on the
wall but guess what I bomb twice last
night so I got those two bombs out of
the way for the [ __ ] week or two you
were saying so that's my percentages I
don't have to get on stage I don't even
have to write do you think I would do
that to you guys I want to show up there
so you guys can go last time he was here
he said that joke but I didn't hear that
that whole new first dirty was all
[ __ ] new that's called respect you
know what guys I get calls from [ __ ]
people all the time Joey your ticket
prices are too low why don't the [ __ ]
you do your ticket price is higher you
come you could charge $45 you could do
this first of all
somebody tweeted me something yesterday
that they paid for a [ __ ] ticket they
got an 18 that dollar [ __ ] service
fee you think I make any money out of
that service fee do you think I'm happy
about that 18 [ __ ] dollars on top of
what they charging me to play that
[ __ ] theater no I'm not happy about
it but there's nothing we could do
it's a cost to doing business Pearl Jam
went the war would [ __ ] Ticketmaster
in the 90s a lot of users were too young
to remember and they lost and they could
only do two for Ticketmaster shows a
year and they had to go on tour with
[ __ ] different bands and there was a
nightmare what would you want mommy to
play some [ __ ] rock'n'roll club were
you gonna get hit in the head with a
[ __ ] bottle so I got no [ __ ]
choice yeah go back to the club and
after I saw the $18 service charge
I will go back to a club and guess what
I'll keep my tickets moderately why it's
called respect
I'm not waiting if I charge you 40 fine
what's I gonna do it's not gonna make me
a break me it's not going to turn me
into a [ __ ] multi-millionaire so why
would I break you because I know in my
heart that you have a babysitter you
have drinks before a restaurant you have
so many hidden cost beside that dirty
dollar ticket parking a condom you know
whatever the [ __ ] you this cost so if I
[ __ ] say yeah $48 50s or some ticket
prices this year for [ __ ] that I almost
[ __ ] died I almost [ __ ] died I
don't know how these [ __ ] people
could sleep at night I see listen the
stones they want 900 they deserve 900
that's 50 years [ __ ] when you're doing
something 50 years whether it's sucking
dick the plane thumping the drums I'll
give you [ __ ] night I'll do the
ticket you know I'm saying they want
like 900 a ticket
the stones deserve it but I see ticket
prices I don't know how people could
sleep at night when I go to a Dodger
game do you know how guilty I feel
because I know the normal family of four
cannot go to these games with these
ticket prices unless they sit with
animals and so they're two little kids
got a hair [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] or [ __ ] night and smoke
pot and see syringes you never know what
the [ __ ] you're gonna see at these
stadiums okay ed with a bottle
so the normal American family
you know when I was a kid you know how
guilty I feel that I went to to 200
[ __ ] the games growing up minimum 200
NIC games I don't know how many [ __ ]
concerts I went to 1250 a ticket 850 a
ticket five dollars a ticket now a
[ __ ] Laker game mystery huh now is a
family of four what I got 1200 hours for
from plus $50 to park plus tan $18 hot
dog that's not respecting your fans
that's not respecting nothing that's
just going you you see what we we get
robbed at every [ __ ] level of our day
whether it's flying there's always that
hidden [ __ ] feet you know so respect
to me as always has been all around this
game whether it's doing my time on stage
listen man I could look youse all in the
face and tell you in 22 years I ran the
light one time at the Comedy Store there
was a month ago I didn't I saw the light
I thought I saw it I didn't see you know
how many joints I smoked today I didn't
know what I [ __ ] saw you know many
times I've come off before I even saw
the light because people have flashed
yeah a picture at me and I thought it
was a light like you know so I've been
in all those places but I ran the light
for the first time in 22 years at the
store a month ago on a Saturday night at
9:15 because I was closing the show and
they really know how much distance I had
that was the first time ever nobody's
ever had to come up to me and say
something to me nobody's had to come up
to me that's and I and you know what if
you know anything about me I'm the type
of guy that would do 25 and walk off I
know what the [ __ ] are you looking at
but that really wouldn't make me a comic
I said it's already I'm not part of the
team you don't see my pictures and half
these joints nobody talks to me I don't
get invited to Festival general then
invites me to festivals is my [ __ ]
mange and [ __ ] crazy man the [ __ ]
Lewis J comas don't know some family you
think I get invited to to the Big Sky
festival all these little festivals
where I go anyway not really but you
know I'm saying I mean nobody thinks I
mean for that shoot which is good
because that won't go anyway but that
that's big
so we're I mean III know it's gonna
you're gonna say respect but going back
40 years you were breaking in things and
now like so what what change what
happened that now you feel bad for
people because they can't afford to go
to a doctor like like that that's a big
switch well I didn't have respect for
myself I obviously didn't have respect
for nothing around me okay as I got
older as I saw the loser that I was it
was proven to me I know for a fact that
I when I started respecting things I
came around more as a human being it
than what I was you know to some people
I joke around I was in bad shape guys
from the ages of 19 to 31 or 32 I was
not a normal individual I did a lot of
bad things I robbed a lot of things I
robbed [ __ ] Christmas
I mean it didn't stop my fingers I was
sticky fingers I know what it is to be
sticky fingered you know it would make
my dick get hard I don't know why I
don't know why does it make my dick get
hard like that - laughs no I goof around
I tell you guys that Rob lives for so
long I don't have the heart I know it's
bad calm and whatever for years I had no
respect for anything through the years
from doing family I learned respect I
learned how cheering against somebody is
not good you know when they're on stage
you cheer for them to do well you cheer
for your friends to comics around you
you know you help other comics the
people that are around you you throw
them gigs are you give them a sheet of
paper with a bunch of Booker's numbers
on it you know when I started people
would give me Booker's numbers
constantly here you go man call them do
the work
call him send the tape call him you know
so because of that respect I got in the
comedy world it taught me something like
it just taught me to tighten my game and
the respect I had to have for people
you know like I said just because I
don't agree with your politics if you
did something like I don't like politics
but one of my favorite guy in politics
is Ross Perot I rest his soul I respect
something that he did he went to an
American family that their family had
gotten kidnapped in Iran or one of those
countries in 80 something 70s and he
told them he promised him he'd be home
by Christmas Day and he kept his promise
that's what a man does
that's that made me respect him you know
I went to prison I don't I don't I mean
it pities me it makes me sad when we
give people respect who did something
disrespectful kind of in a way to get to
where they were if I was still selling
coke or I was a thief or I still burn
people that I wouldn't deserve your
respect but because of the time I put in
the years of sacrifice to sleeping on
Greyhound buses you know this was this
was not I mean you guys have been
posting pictures of me and scare tactics
and today somebody posted a picture me
and some old it's not like I just popped
up on YouTube one day and I'm a youtube
sensation I've been busting my hump
doing this since 1991 and that means
something that really means something
even today if I was doing comedy and I
was still fighting for my life and bars
with Lee and getting $200 a night and
all that type of [ __ ] guess what guys
I would still respect myself the way I
am now for to putting in the work and
sticking with it you know what man when
you come to me you say you quit because
you didn't think you had the chops I
tell you one the truth of the matter is
over the years I've met people in this
town that have had deep philosophical
deep conversations I gave them hours of
my time I gave them hours of my soul I
turned the mother
things and one day I bumped in firmly go
I don't do comedy no more was I mad at
them Nellore
was I upset with them I don't know what
their situation is you know I bumped
into Stephanie s cajeta Stephanie asked
hey there used to be dunking the girl
from very funny comic she got sick for a
while she got back she fell in love and
she got married I've always loved
Stephanie asked and me and Stefan is
cajeta went to [ __ ] La Jolla we used
to go together as a pair as a couple
like not as a couple couple but she was
my feature after I would take her down
and she's left in the living room and
she's a spanish girl came from great
stock of families adopters in mexico and
they ran a hospital just great
phenomenal woman [ __ ] guess what man
she met a guy and they fell in love and
she got knocked up she had a kid he's a
rider and if you watch TV at night she's
in every two commercial breaks she's in
a [ __ ] commercial well I bumped into
her I gave her a hug I gave her a kiss I
got in the car was I mad at her for
quitting so she goes I don't go down and
I'm why I gave it up she goes I miss it
because I still write jokes and I still
tell myself I'm gonna go up but she's
like shall we have a mom did I get mad
not and get mad at her at all was I
disappointed no I wasn't disappointed or
guess what she's still booking
commercials she still take him what she
learned that the Kombi stolen applying
her trade and every time I see or on TV
I [ __ ] cheer for you know but I
bumped into people that came here and
they and I'm not saying they took
something from you personally they took
ten minutes of your time I saw them at
the store talking to rogue I saw them
asking questions here and one day I
don't know where left field they're like
I quit comedy be a producer I can't deal
with you because you put so much time
into it you put so much time into it ago
has [ __ ] minute you just gave it all
up can I lose this back for you I listen
no no no not at all but I lost
I lost it a little bit of respect for
you not that I won't talk to you that
but I won't help you if you're in a jam
but I lost a little bit of respect for
you because of how you're gonna feel if
you don't think I feel terrible about
myself for what I did when I was 15
years old when I quit basketball
you got nothing come one confession I
can make you guys is that I was just
recently I recently got comfortable
watching basketball again maybe 10 years
ago four years I didn't even watch the
NBA I didn't even watch college because
even though I turned out to be [ __ ]
510 500 pounds I was still mad at myself
for quitting basketball when I was 15
years old till this day I'm still mad at
a couple things I did I never forgave
myself I never forgave myself from
acquitting Karate I never forgave myself
of a quitting basketball you know a
couple things but those are the most two
because I just gave up on them that was
a type of person that I was that I had
no respect for myself I just gave up one
day just gave up just gave up no fight
no nothing I put an end date and I gave
it up and I'm late
I stuck to the end date you know at
least I was good about that I respected
the date for karate was February 19th
1979 and that's the day my life changed
forever my [ __ ] mother died six
months later and for [ __ ] basketball
I don't know what I quit basketball like
that was it what's freshman year and
then I was so [ __ ] upset but I just
quit I just quit completely and started
doing drugs if you don't think I lost
respect over myself and it took me years
to gain self-respect and even with
family you think when I did The Longest
Yard
I had self-respect I was still a sack of
[ __ ] even though I accomplished
something that few people could
accomplish without an agent sending a
tape and going in there and taking what
was mine because I didn't take no for a
[ __ ] answer
I didn't give a [ __ ] okay like big [ __ ]
or Sara goose or whatever the [ __ ] they
want it they're not comics and they
never [ __ ] and now
the first time in my mind that I really
gained respect because I said to myself
[ __ ] that they're not taking that from
me that belongs to me and I'm gonna get
it one way or the other and I [ __ ]
got it did that does that make me better
than you man at all not at all
I'm still that [ __ ] guy that quit
basketball and quit [ __ ] karate and
was robbed and stuff like that
it made it a little better what gave me
the respect that I have for myself today
is that stuck with Kali and I stuck with
it when I was in the lowest lowest part
of my life
well they had a walk away from a
daughter and living in a [ __ ]
basement and sleeping in a car and
through all that I saw something and
today I deliver myself a lot better than
I did when I was [ __ ] 30 how does
that one fight so whatever you try and
do in your life I know we spoke about
frustration and respect should be in
there to learn what you should respect
which should be everything which should
be everything I mean I'm at the point at
80% I respect things now socially and
around me I can't respect that 20%
because it wouldn't make me atomic it's
like I totally the other day on the
phone
in the daytime he's mush that's his name
take a look at him smile for the camera
that's mush when he gets on stage he's
Lisa at he eats ass
he sucks [ __ ] if he has to jump off the
building you know when I'm walking
around the daytime now I'm just Joey
Diaz I'm just Joey Diaz and I have a
child and I talked to my wife and I love
my wife and we have coffee in the
morning and we try to hang out at night
when I go on stage I'm Charlie cocoa
dance and I'm I'm kind of responsible
for what he says but I don't want to be
responsible for what he says because
that's what makes me [ __ ] dangerous
so thank you for listening and thank you
for taking the time and I hope this
conversation helped you a little bit
before we go
do not forget next Friday I'm at the
Lincoln Theater and Saturday I'm at the
ball god it's all sold out I can't read
it I can't wait to see you [ __ ]
I just added the 24th the August to the
Icehouse a little work
before Labor Day weekend and we got San
Antonio we got Dallas we got Chicago at
the Chicago theater go to Joey beers
dotnet Froy your dates real quick before
you leave listen I talked to you at the
beginning of the show about a few things
I want to reiterate here I want to talk
to you guys about upstart okay listen I
know you're at that age you got on the
college listen most of us have found out
the hard way getting out getting into
debt is easy getting out of debt is the
hard part especially if your FICO score
isn't just great thankfully there's
upstart calm well up start calm does
their revolutionary lending platform
that knows more than just your credit
score and office smaller interest rates
to help you pay off high interest credit
card debt listen from 91 to 92 thousand
11 I was pretty much in that and it's
it's it's a nightmare situation to be in
if you need help this is the way to go
because upstart goes beyond the
traditional FICO score when assessing
your creditworthiness they actually
reward you based on your education and
your job history in the form of a
smarter interest rate okay
upstart believes you're more than just a
credit score they believe in you and
they understand that so they make it
fast simple and easy to check your rate
in just a few minutes without affecting
your credit score are you hearing me
without affecting your credit your
credit score the best part is once the
loan is approved most people get their
funds the very next business day the
next business day so you could be on
your way to taking care of this prep of
this credit problem immediately over
200,000 people have used up start to pay
off credit cards student loans fund
their weddings or just make a large
purchase free yourself from burden of
high interest credit card debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment would up start now see
why upstart is ranked number
one in that category with over 300
businesses on Trustpilot and Harry the
upstart comm slash shirts to find out
how low your upstart rate is checking
your rate only takes a few minutes and
again it will not affect your credit
score so do me a favor
find out how low your up start rate is
by going to upstart comm slash Church
again that's upstart comm slash Church
CH you are CH the church is also brought
to you by my favorite on it listen what
can I say about for seven years I mean
I've been using honor products for
Ballena nine years especially the Alpha
brain keeps me sharp keeps me in tuned I
do a little cycle from time to time I'm
about to start another one I love alpha
brain shroom tech immune I can't live
without shoot export I use but it makes
my lungs go too crazy but I love it to
death do me a favor going on a.com right
now take a look at the great supplements
they have to offer you from the whey
protein powder to the MCT oil I mean
they have some products I will blow your
[ __ ] mind go to Alec calm right now
press in church and get the best
supplements to live it right to your
door and I'm gonna give me 10% off okay
plus they're having a tremendous sale
anywhere right now
so go Donna calm right now press in
church and get started today with the
Alpha brand so you're ready by the
[ __ ] holidays to stab a [ __ ]
than that you know anyway I want to
thank I want to thank upstart calm I
want to thank Anna calm but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
another great week of the church don't
forget it's August 1st [ __ ]
it's on [ __ ] we got five more [ __ ]
months to justify our existence before
2020 comes in five months 2020 what the
[ __ ] are you thinking do me a favor
Lincoln Theatre next went on a Friday
night the 9th of August they're still
tickets available and that's it and
that's that we'll see you bright and
early Monday morning tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo ready to get you
started for another week all right I
love you [ __ ] stay black and see
you Monday morning
go kick this [ __ ] really